this is Startalk let's take a query
let's go to the queries this is cory
Garst coming to us from Google+ what
kind of research has been done to show
what effects GMOs do or do not have on
humans well this is exactly the point
this is Thank You Cory is that a that is
Cory gharst from glasses
from out there so what they we it has
done is that is the one thing you can
test is the effects of food I mean this
one straightforward thing you can test
that's that's not that different from
twenty years ago
you feed the food to your good friends
the lab rats okay yeah and you and the
mice and you say what do you think right
so Steve that's the mouse's name Steve
Henrietta
right as long as it's not Mickey you're
fine uh I think
Mickey's really hard it's a hard lab rat
to have to make well to kill would be
manually hard right yeah well for some
so the thing is there's no the
genetically modified food has no effect
on us I mean that is to say there's no
difference between it and organically
raised food this is scientifically
provable ok certainly provable to my
satisfaction and that's like the most
straightforward thing about it is to see
if it still is nutritious and Steve see
if it has any allergy effect and it
absolutely does not in fact in general
all of these foods are more nutritious
there are bigger is the first time I've
ever heard that assertion well just in
general I mean you get more soybean per
hectare per acre like that you get more
corn per acre per hectare you get bigger
kernels of corn so from a voluminous
standpoint I'm not just said if you're
gonna if the if the bushel of corn ways
so many kilos are pounds how much of
that is nutritious corn and how much of
that is cob unedible inedible ok that's
a very good play yes you get a lot more
you get a lot more kernel than cob yeah
and just in that one example the famous
example then the other thing that's
happened
with genetically modified foods and this
maybe in the in the future queries the
other thing that's happened is it's led
to the success of this technology of
allowing you to put glyphosate on fields
and then plant things like crazy is
people have raised enormous tracts of
land in a single crop because it's
easier
gotcha and this is so-called monoculture
and this has had two things first of all
you you lose diversity in your farming
and which leads to a loss of diversity
in the microbes that support plants and
a loss of diversity in the the the rate
at which different pollinate able
flowers appear this is to say okay if
all the soybean plants come to go to
flower at the same time the bees have to
work that whole deal right
they can't go from this plant to that
plant to this plant you'll notice the
cherry blossoms show up first right and
that's their trick right so the bees and
everybody they show up and they're like
hey you know what cherry blossoms can I
say do oh yes you do what they're doing
the way you know Burnet bees that's
right we know when the John cools show
up then the daffodils and there's a
sequence that has come-to by the way
clearly the horrors of the plant world
the daffodils but I'm just saying it's
just on your mind just on your mind
consenting adult it's all good
harvestable plants right no so this has
led to monoculture but I go along with
the idea I mean I know I claim that the
success of genetic modification with
respect to glyphosate herbicide does not
necessarily mean you plant a monoculture
and stress out be colonies that's you
you could that's not the cause and
effect that's so funny when you say that
I just hear Jerry Seinfeld going what
are we gonna do there's so many flowers
all at once that was a terrible Jerry
sign it was also my understanding that
was you doing Jerry Seinfeld bee bee bee
yes a female bee yes exactly
yeah so I brought by the way all the
bees you see
girls they're all females I seldom see
because they kick the drones out as soon
as they're finished mating with the
Queen and it's just like they go
straight Beyonce to the left to the left
all your stuff in a box to the left
get out awful I'll keep that in mind
should I become a drone be a drone be a
true but phenomenally the way you
started it sounds like good work if you
can get it yeah it does in a way so
there's no difference in allergic
reaction and and health concerns with
respect to genetically modified foods
worth compared with organic or
non-genetically modified food we know
that because the research has been done
on mice oh well on mice and people I'm
people it's been going on for almost 25
years fantastic and nobody gets sick
from it in fact people are in general
they get more food from a given hectare
or acre of land and the strange thing
that was pointed out to me and I did
some research well over 90% of the
world's farmers are small farmers right
and they all use Roundup Ready crops or
genetically modified crops because
they're just so much more productive
okay so as I say about glyphosate and
I'm not an expert on roundup this is my
thing but I've done some research
there's two things that happen when
roundup was introduced first of all
everybody was afraid of it because it
does kill every green plant was that
something to be afraid of then the
second thing is everybody started using
it because it works so well this is the
the troubling bifurcated effect hey this
is scary as hell I know what we should
all use it well that's happened okay all
right hey Cory that was a great question
and and a great answer by mr. Bill Nye
all right I love you chuck this is
Startalk